IS THAT WELCOME BACK TO THIS
SPECIAL EDITION OF "TUCKER
CARLSON TONIGHT."
THREE YEARS AGO, THINK ABOUT
THIS, BARACK OBAMA WAS
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
BUT NOW HIS LEGACY OF THE
CHIEF EXECUTIVE IS DRAWING UP.
FIRST TRUMP CAME IN AND BEGAN
UNDOING THE POLICIES.
BUT NOW EVEN THE DEMOCRATS ARE
TURNING ON THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
IN THE LAST DEMOCRATIC DEBATE
ROUND CANDIDATES TOOK TURN
BASHES JOE BIDEN FOR HIS
CONNECTION TO THE OBAMA
POLICIES FOR OTHER ISSUES.
NOW NEW REPORT SAYS OBAMA
URGED BIDEN NOT TO RUN AND IS
WORRIED THAT HIS GAFFE-FILLED
CAMPAIGN WILL FURTHER DAMAGE
OBAMA'S LEGACY.
BUCK SEXTON IS GOING TO GIVE
US CLARITY ON THIS.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON
TONIGHT.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tammy: THIS IS AN
INTERESTING TURN OF EVENTS.
WE KNOW THAT BARACK OBAMA
DESTROYED THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
WITH OBAMACARE AND THE 2010
SHIFT.
THEY LOST A HUGE NUMBER OF THE
BACK BENCH, THE TALENT BACK
BENCH.
IT WAS NOT WORRIED ABOUT -- HE
WAS NOT WORRIED ABOUT THE
HEALTH OF THE PARTY GOING
FORWARD OR MAJOR MESSAGING.
DO YOU THINK NOW THAT -- BIDEN
IS STILL NICELY AHEAD IN THE
POLLS.
DO YOU THINK THIS PROBLEM WILL
BE WHAT UNDOES HIM AND PUTS
SOMEONE ELSE AS THE FRONT
RUNNER?
>> BIDEN HAS BEEN THE
CANDIDATE IN THE LEAD UP TO
THIS POINT THROUGH DEFAULT AND
HE HAS BEEN RIDING ON THE
FUMES OF THE OBAMA PRESIDENCY.
HE DOESN'T HAVE OBAMA'S
COATTAILS ANYMORE TO HOLD ON
TO.
WHEN PEOPLE LEARN MORE ABOUT
HIM AS A CANDIDATE THEY START
TO THINK WHO IS THIS GUY
EXACTLY?
FOR EIGHT YEARS HE WAS V.P.
HE WAS SOMEBODY YEAH, HE WAS
AT A LOT OF EVENTS.
HIS NAME RECOGNITION WENT UP
DRAMATICALLY, WHICH IS A BIG
DIFFERENCE OF 2008 WHEN HE
COULDN'T GET MORE THAN 5% IN
ANY POLL BECAUSE PEOPLE DIDN'T
KNOW WHO HE WAS.
EIGHT YEARS AS V.P., THEY
THINK OKAY, CONTINUATION OF
THE OBAMA LEGACY.
BUT THEN HILLARY SWOOPED IN
AND WAS THE CANDIDATE LAST
TIME AROUND.
IF HE WAS SO GREAT, WHY WASN'T
HE THE GUY THEN?
HE SEEMS TO BE THE GUY NOW
BECAUSE NOBODY ELSE HAS COME
TO THE FOREFRONT THAT THE
PARTY CAN GET BEHIND.
I SAY SOME OF THE NEW THINGS
THAT ARE COMING UP LIKE MAYBE
THEY WON'T GIVE HIM SO MANY
EVENTS LATE IN THE DAY OR COME
ONE A NEW WAY SO HE DOESN'T
GET TIRED.
WE WANT FIND WAYS TO MAKE IT
EADESSIER FOR HIM.
>> Tammy: THE PRIMARY SEASON
IS FOR THAT.
YOU FIND OUT WHAT PEOPLE ARE
MADE OF.
YOU LEARN WHO THEY ARE.
YOU HAVE SOME NAME RECOGNITION
WITH VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN.
THAT IS IT.
BUT YOU FIND OUT, THAT IS HOW
PEOPLE LEARNED ABOUT TRUMP.
YOU FIND OUT IF SOMEONE IS
CONSISTENT AND WHO THEY ARE.
IF THEY ARE GOING TO TALK
ABOUT THE POLICY.
IT'S NOT A JOKE.
THE PRESIDENT HAS HIGH ENERGY.
IF YOU HAVE THE ENERGY AND THE
WHEREWITHAL TO DEAL WITH THIS.
AND WE SAW THAT REPORT IN "THE
HILL.
" TO STOP GAFFES MAYBE THEY
NEED HIM TO STOP TALKING AT
CERTAIN POINTS.
I WILL ONLY GET MORE INTENSE,
ISN'T IT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Tammy: AS MORE PEOPLE
FALL OUT FROM THE DEMOCRATS
AND YOU HAVE A GENERAL
ELECTION.
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE FOR THEM.
>> NOT JUST THE PRESSURE THAT
WILL INCREASE WHEN THERE ARE
FEWER CANDIDATES IN THE RACE.
CLEARLY BIDEN WILL BE AROUND
FOR QUITE SOME TIME.
IT'S ALSO WHEN ALL OF A SUDDEN
DONALD TRUMP WHO WE SAW LAST
NIGHT IN THE USUAL FORM HE
SHOWS, WHICH IS A GUY WHO IS
AN ENTERTAINER WITH A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF ENERGY
AND ALSO A FIGHTER, ESPECIALLY
ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
THEY WILL HAVE JOE BIDEN UP
AGAINST HIM.
KEEP IN MIND, YOU HAVE HAD THE
DEMOCRATS SAYING THAT TRUMP
DOESN'T HAVE THE MENTAL
FACULTY TO BE PRESIDENT.
THEY TALK ABOUT THE 25th
AMENDMENT.
AS A RESULT, YOU WILL LOOK AT
BIDEN'S AGE, THE TEMPERAMENT,
THE ENERGY, THAT IS ALL
COMPLETELY FAIR GAME STUFF
NOW.
WHEN YOU SEE THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY REPUDIATING AS THEY DID
ON THE LAST DEBATE OBAMA'S
LEGACY --
>> Tammy: I GOT TO ASK YOU,
THOUGH, I GOT TO ASK YOU THIS.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THAT PEOPLE
SAY BARACK OBAMA'S CONCERNED
ABOUT JOE BIDEN.
AND HE IS CONCERNED ABOUT THE
CAMPAIGN.
IS THAT WHAT BARACK OBAMA IS
REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT WHEN HE
TRIES TO STOP JOE BIDEN FROM
TALKING OR RUNNING?
>> NO.
THIS IS A VERY -- THIS IS AN
OBAMAISM.
YOU MENTIONED AT THE START OF
THE SEGMENT, OBAMA WAS
INCREDIBLY SUCCESSFUL RUNNING
FOR HIMSELF AT DIFFERENT
POINTS IN THE POLITICAL
CAMPAIGN.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY WAS IN
SHAMBLES WHEN HE WAS DONE.
HIS SUCCESS NEVER TRANSLATED
TO OTHER PEOPLE.
>> Tammy: IT WILL HAPPEN
THIS TIME.
>> THEY ARE HOPING THAT BIDEN
GETS SURPASSED BUT DOESN'T
COLLAPSE.
THAT IS WHY OBAMA IS STEPPING
IN.